This brings us to the final section of our course.
Let's wrap things up by going over a few tips and resources you may find helpful when working with metahumans in your project.
We will jump back into Unreal Engine to go over some of these.
One thing you may encounter when working with a metahuman in your scene is you may accidentally select one of the components instead of the actual blueprint.
One way to prevent this and to also move your metahuman around in your scene with ease is to use an actor.
Go to the Get Content panel, then go to Basic and select Actor.
In the Details panel, with the actor selected, reset the transform settings to zero for the actor,
and ensure the position of the metahuman in the level has also been zeroed out.
Now, in the Outliner, drag the metahuman blueprint over the actor to make it a child of the actor.
And now, you can use the actor to move the metahuman around in the scene.
This will also prevent the metahuman from reverting back to its default pose and position when moving it around when it has an animation applied to it.
Now, before we move on, let's review the steps we just completed.
We have looked at how we can use an actor to move our metahuman around in our level.
To add an actor to the level, go to the Get Content panel, then go to Basic and select Actor.
Zero out the position of both the actor and metahuman, and in the Outliner, drag the metahuman blueprint over the actor to make it a child of the actor.
Now, let's continue by jumping back into Unreal Engine.
There may be cases where you have been using a metahuman as a placeholder to block out a scene and are now ready to bring in your final version,
or you simply want to replace it with a different metahuman.
A simple way to do this is to add the metahuman you wish to use in the level.
Then, in the Outliner, select the metahuman you want to replace.
Right-click on it and select Replace Actors With, and then select the metahuman blueprint you want in its place.
And now, we can delete this one and continue working.
Let's review the steps we just completed.
If you want to replace an existing metahuman in a scene with a new one, add the metahuman you want to replace the existing one with into the level.
In the Outliner, select the metahuman you want to replace.
Right-click on it, select Replace Actor With, and then select the metahuman you want to replace it with.
Now, let's go over a few other things worth mentioning when working with metahumans.
When working with metahumans, at some point you may be considering changing engine versions.
Determine which engine version you will be using as that will define available feature sets for your metahuman.
If you decide to upgrade metahumans in a project, just note that there will be a series of steps you will need to go through to ensure you have successfully updated them.
Metahumans can only be upgraded as previous versions have several variations in skeletal joint systems or blueprint setups that prevent downgrading.
We saw with our hands-on exercise how we can use the metahuman plugin and the mesh-to-metahuman workflow to generate a metahuman identity from a 3D model to achieve likeness with our character.
You can also generate a metahuman identity from footage using depth footage from an iPhone or vertical stereo head-mounted camera.
The template mesh workflow, also referred to as conformed mesh, solves a metahuman identity using the mesh-to-metahuman workflow based on geometry.
The only requirement is that the 3D mesh uses the same topology as a metahuman mesh.
This workflow results in better fitting of geometry in joints.
The DNA calibration tools allow you to go beyond the metahuman creator and the mesh-to-metahuman workflow in order to push likeness even further.
We delve into these workflows in greater detail in the metahuman DNA calibration courses.
When integrating metahumans into your pipeline, keep in mind there will be a learning curve.
As mentioned at the start of this course, the metahuman framework is made up of a variety of collaborating parts.
Having an understanding of each of these assets and how they work together seamlessly is vital to the learning process.
This can help when making decisions on how to approach modifying the different assets, what and where to look if something is not working,
and what changes have been made to feature sets as engine versions update.
With each new release of metahumans and feature sets, the end user license agreement may be updated or amended
to reflect changes to the legal document that explains a user's rights and obligations related to the use of metahuman technology.
This can include the metahuman creator, the metahuman plugin for Unreal Engine, metahuman animator, and any other related Epic Games assets and technologies.
For Unreal Engine versions 5.5 and earlier, metahuman assets are licensed for use in Unreal Engine projects, meaning users must render metahumans with Unreal Engine.
Be sure to read the full agreement carefully. You can locate your ULA history in your user account on the Unreal Engine website.
Finally, all of the online resources and links to some of the tools discussed today can be found by following the URLs on this slide.
Feel free to pause here or take a screenshot for later reference.
This brings us to the end of the metahuman introduction course.
I want to thank you for spending your time with me, and I hope that these videos help you as you continue working with metahumans in Unreal Engine.